Даші 7 років, а її психоемоційний розвиток
відповідає тримісячній дитині.
Вона не говорить, не сидить самостійно і не розуміє слів.
У дівчинки - фарм-резистентна форма епілепсії.
Щодня вона переживає до 15 нападів.
Кожен призводить до відмирання клітин головного мозку.
- 10-15 хвилин її зводить судоми. Ручки і ніжки.
Ось так сильно. Через 10 хвилин попустило,
вона засинає така виснажена.
І потім хвилин через чорок чи годину знову приступ.
І потім знову, знову…
Препарати, які виписують згідно з протоколом українські медики,
мали б блокувати напади.
Це дозволило б зайнятися реабілітацією дівчинки.
Утім, ці ліки не допомагають, а навпаки:
через численні побічні ефекти, серед яких сонливість,
приносять додаткові муки.
Саме під час змін фаз сну у дівчинки і стаються напади.
Аби зменшити страждання дитини, Ольга готова йти на експерименти.
Рік тому в інтернеті знайшла інформацію
про випадок використання такою ж хворою дитиною
медичного канабісу в сусідній Польщі,
де рослина дозволена в медичних цілях.
- До прийому канабісу дитина в стані овоча.
Не тримає голову, не тримає язика і так далі.
І вже після того -
осмислений погляд, посміхається дитина,
радіє життю. І пояснення мами:
тільки поодинокі судомні напади на місяць.
Вже є контакт з ним.
Марихуана частково легальна у 30 країнах світу,
ще в 14 її використовують у медицині.
В Україні ж канабіс вважається небезпечним наркотиком.
За його збут можна отримати до 12 років позбавлення волі.
Також через заборону українські вчені
не можуть проводити дослідження цієї рослини
і орієнтуються на міжнародний досвід.
Уже відомо, що відчуття так званого "кайфу"
під час куріння марихуани викликає тетрагідроканабінол,
а от другий компонент цих рослин - канабідіол -
має знеболювальний ефект.
Саме з цієї речовини і виготовляють спреї, пігулки
чи олію для сигарет, які зменшують біль хворих.
Утім, вплив цієї речовини ще вивчається
і можуть бути серйозні побічні наслідки.
- Оце так виглядає, бачиш.
Відома телеведуча та акторка Яніна Соколова
публічно виступає за легалізацію медичного канабісу.
Після хіміотерапії вона, як практично кожен онкохворий,
відчувала пекельний біль. Аби мінімізувати його,
курила електронну цигарку з оліями канабісу.
- За 26 доларів. Саме стільки коштує такий футлярчик,
в якому така сигарета електронна і капсула
з олією канабісу, якої вистачає приблизно на три місяці.
Яка без побічної дії зробить мінімум больових синдромів.
Мені цей футляр привезли зі США,
бо в Україні купити неможливо і може каратись
відповідальністю адміністративною.
Відповідно в Україні зась.
Неурядові організації вже подали до Верховної Ради
законопроект про легалізацію медичного канабісу.
Зоя Заміховська з Української асоціації медичного канабісу
теж розробляла цей документ. За її словами,
за ним - розвиток цілої галузі від культивації рослини
і виготовлення препаратів до зберігання і знищення.
Експертка запевняє, що всіх, хто буде причетний
до обігу марихуани, суворо контролюватиме держава,
а порушників каратимуть.
- Якщо ми говоримо про правильне
використання або застосування за законом
і в рамках прописаної процедури,
то я навіть не можу придумати якісь негативи.
Якщо говоримо про зловживання,
наприклад, отримання пацієнтом, який не має рецепту,
то це радше виняток і
зараз це відбувається і з іншими лікарськими засобами.
Це недобросовісність провізора, фармацевта
і пацієнта.
Але це не та пропорція, через яку потрібно загалом
цю можливість відкидати або забороняти.
Прибічники легалізації впевнені у відсутності ризиків вживання канабісу.
Вони посилаються на висновки експертів ВООЗ із наркотичної залежності,
які минулого року визнали потенціал медичного канабісу
для терапевтичного та наукового використання.
Утім, у тому ж дослідженні йдеться і про шкоду для здоров’я,
яку несе канабіс. Довгострокові побічні наслідки
вживання таких препаратів ще недостатньо досліджені.
Ці ризики Ользі відомі, але вона все одно б
спробувала такий метод лікування,
щоби зменшити страждання своєї доньки.